the democrats are going to be the last
of the institutionalists this is one
reason why i individually or forward
it's like it's kind of its own thing and
the republicans are the
anti-institutionalists
uh and then and you're in a time when by
the way the institutions are not exactly
kicking ass they're not thriving yeah
yeah they're failing many of them
um and so
in a way what you need is kind of benign
outsiders
but
the democratic party will be hostile
towards even benign outsiders government
has not been run very well
in decades
yet
in order to
win a democratic primary or race you
have to have
experience running these poorly run
institutions well i made a joke about in
my book which was that like uh it's like
the test is like how can we be sure that
you also will get nothing done
[Laughter]
you know i mean yeah i forgot that yeah
the people take like kind of fake credit
for like oh under my watch like these
things happen i passed this bill that no
one's ever never heard of
we increased funding to xyz he was like
man that increases every year with or
without you you know
[Music]
this week zach and i make some bold
headline making predictions for 2022 the
year ahead this week on forward
[Music]
it's 2022. it's 2022. this is gonna be
the year
this is our year andrew in all
seriousness i tell people close to me
that you should try and enjoy yourself
this year because next year is going to
be
become
unfortunately an obsession with 2024 at
least politically and culturally
uh so 2022 has got to be the year
i was just gonna say this is the year we
take back the white house but that's a
bad joke
yeah that
doesn't make any sense but it is our
year and i'm i'm feeling
great about this year we're going to do
some awesome stuff we're going to build
up
so we had some end-of-year forward party
stuff
including a new year's eve celebration
online that was really invigorating and
delightful so thank you to everyone
who's a part of that uh you know we're
off to a rousing start so it's our
2022 outlook episode
where you the listener get to hear
andrew yang's
and mine if you're interested
predictions for the year
yes what lies ahead in 2022 and we were
pretty
we don't have to dive into last year's
predictions but we weren't that bad last
year we were pretty
our 2021 outlooks were pretty good
um so apparently we predicted it was
going to be a [ __ ] year and then it was
like ding ding ding i had rich predicted
education institutions not going great
which i they haven't really fallen but i
think they're still pretty shitty i
predicted new media uh
outlets to emerge and i think substance
a good example
of such uh feeling good about that
there's a couple others but sub sex by
the big one
um
roaring twenties in my prediction last
year and i don't know if it really
roared the new theme is going to be
growflation
that's like the
term i'm coining um which i i suppose
will lead me into our first prediction
of the new year what we got i think
inflation is persistent and here to stay
and i think not maybe at this six
percent level that we've experienced but
i talked to a macro
hedge fund analyst
who
said that she thinks inflation's here to
stay and here's why this made perfect
sense to me
is that most firms use something called
fifo accounting if any of you were nerd
and learned this stuff at some point
which is first in first out first and
first out yep so if you were to take a
very very simple business like a chair
manufacturing business
and you had inventory of you know a
thousand chairs in your warehouse
now those chairs were built and then
let's say your prices went up in terms
of lumber which they probably did
so you build some new chairs but the new
chairs
being more expensive it doesn't kick in
until you clear the old chairs
because you already built those chairs
out of wood that was cheaper so what's
going to happen to that firm is that
when they sell that thousand and first
chair that cost them more in order to
make the same amount of money they're
going to have to charge more so there's
been like a lag time in the system
between what some someone's costs have
been and when they need to start
charging you for their increased costs
so this analyst said look i think a lot
of firms have actually are starting to
make these decisions but there has been
a lag time and so you're going to see it
filter through the system
uh in the next number of weeks and
months which made perfect sense to me
what also made sense to me was that
there's now some
um
expectation of higher prices among
consumers that if you're a business you
can get away with it yeah frankly
you know i walked into a bagel store the
other day and they said hey we've
increased prices because our costs have
gone up like uh hope you're cool with
that
you know what i said you're cool
oh yeah then i saw that and i shrugged
and was like i guess i'm cool with that
but you you see that in a range of
businesses and so if you were a business
who was on the fence then you'd be like
well if i raise my prices my my
customers will assume it's because i had
to
uh the other thing you're seeing is that
a lot of businesses are having a hard
time staffing
and so they are
giving people raises or higher
higher wages
and i think that's good but that's also
going to result in prices going up
for those businesses so inflation's
going to be persistent in 2022 uh and
that's going to put pressure on the fed
to raise interest rates and the question
then would be how would the market
respond to an interest rate increase and
i'm going to suggest it'd be very very
negative
so
my prediction for 2022 includes
the fact that not only will inflation
be persistent but also we're going to
see a market correction at some point
well that's not thrilling but um
i'm not optimistic but
i think that that checks out and i think
if you're a business
usually when when a business jacks up
prices consumers are pissed they're like
i think they're gouging me right but if
you're a business and you have the
opportunity to raise prices
knowing that your consumers will be like
tolerant of it being like oh yeah this
pie chain
listening to it now costs you
12 you should charge
[Laughter]
okay i think that's a good one um maybe
an easy one and a little pessimistic
i'll do an optimistic one my optimism
you thought it was an easy one you're
mocking my prediction
i'm not mocking
you're saying it's too obvious i think
it's an obvious one i don't know if it's
obvious
the other thing i think the press
narrative will that will be this will be
interesting the press narrative i think
will be that inflation's decreasing even
though it's still kind of high that's i
think that's what you kind of said like
it might go down a bit but it's still
going to be
we're going to be in
post-inflationary environment or we've
had something of an aberrantly low
inflation environment for an extended
correct time
and then now that inflation's here most
people don't know what to do with it um
there have been a lot of parallels drawn
between jimmy carter and joe biden that
was my growthlation joke because
we had stagflation under carter
it's like you know no growth and
inflation and that's a pretty terrible
combination so now we're going to have
some kind of
growth but inflation's going to be here
so that's my proflation
oh boy poor joe not a good thing no one
wants to be compared to carter i don't
think at least the past number of years
all right my optimistic
2022 prediction will make our crypto
fans happy make my girlfriend happy um
but i think web 3
is gonna be more mainstream it's going
to start to mainstream this year
i don't think
before you freak out my crypto fans who
listen to this podcast i don't think
you're probably gonna see an nft bubble
pop a bit
i think people are outrageously
overpaying for a whole bunch of crypto
things i think any time you're seeing
valuations change massively because
someone threw the world someone threw
the word crypto or web3 onto it is uh
usually a sign of a bubble or over hype
i think if you're a coder right now if
you're learning to code you're being an
engineer you're learning how to code on
the blockchain i think that's gonna
you're gonna start to see mainstream uh
innovation so what do i mean
i wouldn't be surprised if concert
tickets or airlines or so a lot of these
qr codes start just being on the
blockchain um i think you start seeing
web3
baked into our everyday lives and that
is a good thing i think i'm really
excited what that looks like there's a
lot of takes on that i want to type in
you and me on this podcast over the next
coming weeks and months this year um
to talk more on web3 but i do think
that's going to be a more of a
mainstream thing and not a niche thing
wow man you're really going out on a
limb now i'm kidding
[Laughter]
we're warming up they're warming up
warming up yeah
it gets diceier
that's true they get these takes get
hotter as we go
i mean i i certainly agree that uh web
three is going to be um on everyone's
lips this year
and
uh they're gonna be tons of corporates
investing in the metaverse one one of
the things people are concerned about is
whether it's going to replicate existing
dynamics or whether it's going to be
uh broader and more egalitarian you saw
what jack dorsey tweeted oh yeah he said
he's going to replicate the he's a and i
i'm with the amount that i
the whole thing's a problem if it looks
like our venture community now web 3
hasn't done [ __ ] it's the exact same
thing
like meet the old meet the new boss just
like the old boss right like that's what
it is like anytime i do meet someone in
web 3 who is clearly not one of the old
bosses though it does make me happy i
agree like i do run into them and i'm
happy about them there is the
decentralization thing is is exciting
um
the uni the universal basic income
and let's call it monetary access and
reaching the unbanked and things like
that that upside's remarkable like what
we were talking about but
if you're just talking about a bunch of
rich kids
or semi-rich kids getting more rich
living you know at home in a basement
and becoming crypto millionaires and
then just buying real estate in the
metaverse i don't know if that's really
changing much
i don't mean to be mean i love you guys
[Laughter]
i don't know
okay so like i'm seeing like this is
what and like i want someone to come and
i want you guys to respond to this uh
you watch this on youtube or come at me
on twitter but
like i'm seeing
people pay
outrageous prices in the metaverse for
digital real estate or gucci bags and
stuff like this and i'm like so we're
going to have the same
like all the problems we have with our
current
real life world are just are going to be
just as bad in the metaverse like it's
not new in the new one um you know
someone who is into into um
web 3 said something to me that stuck
with me
said that
uh that it's social signaling
um yeah and then when you reflect for a
moment on just how many things we do
that are in essence social signaling
then you start to think okay
what are the limits and the limits are
theoretically
infinite
in that sense you know and it's funny
because you know we're broadcasting this
from manhattan
uh and there are so many things that
people do in new york city that are
social signaling oh yeah you know
it's real people go spend money on it
it's real i'm just saying
we have this awesome opportunity to
change
to start over in a way and it doesn't
seem like we are well one of the the
encouraging things i've found from
talking to folks in this space is that
some people
are catching on that web 3
needs to tackle more real-world problems
and i i'm seeing some very encouraging
initiatives in that
dimension where they're trying to tackle
uh climate change in some cases economic
inequality and poverty in other cases so
that sounds great and anyone who's doing
things like that you know we're going to
try and help yeah and that that is my
prediction is not that
web 3 and blockchain and crypto continue
the hype that's not my prediction my
prediction is web 3 becomes more real
world it starts to interact with real
world app real world application so
um i think verified credentials
um which is basically
eliminating the need for your paper
insurance card or your paper airline
ticket or your driver's license and
doing that online in a very verified
secure way and we've actually had an
episode on that um on this podcast that
stuff is fascinating to me and i think
it'll become more and more mainstream my
dream my dream
is when you can go to a rental car place
when you go to hertz go pick up your
rental card
and you scan your phone and you don't
have to wait in line and talk to a
person it's just it's all verified right
there because what are they verifying
that you want your insurance a real
human being you have a driver's driver's
license and that you're you right and
you have a credit card you could do that
theoretically on the blockchain very
quickly and not have to sit in line and
wait for the person and this sort of
thing so
i don't know that happens this year but
i think
smaller applications of that start
happening and it's pretty exciting
[Music]
okay it is time for the big news making
prediction oh that's it
this is it okay
there will be a significant
third-party
presidential candidate that declares in
22
this is not you declaring for president
right now this is not me declaring right
now but this is me
declaring that someone will declare in
20 i do
declare
for the presidency someone's going to
run as a third party someone's going to
run as a third party and they'll
announce in 2022 and they're going to
announce the 22. i even think
they're going to announce before the
midterms
wow well the midterms are in november
um but
hear me out on this
so let's say you are a relatively
significant third party candidate
looking at this field
and you would see okay
joe biden 42 43 popularity on the other
side you have trump coming up
now what is your
cost benefit to waiting
until after the midterms
if you wait until after the midterms
then the oxygen will start going towards
both trump and let's say joe
and
it's going to be
potentially less advantageous to you to
be declaring later if you declare
earlier and if you return to the
bygone days of yang 2020
we declared in february of 2018
which would be
the equivalent of february 22. like
declaring in four weeks it's like
declaring in four weeks
what are four years four 2024 yes
so
why did we make that decision
well we didn't have any
uh at the time we didn't have any uh
notoriety or
recognition
so if you have some time you might as
well spend it stumping around new
hampshire and iowa going around in our
case it was the midwestern um
mid-atlantic
humanity first tour
uh if you were a third-party contender
you might as well get a jump on it
uh you
can use this time let's say you don't
hold elective office uh you don't
necessarily need to be bound up to some
you know geography or role
so you might as well hit iowa summer 22.
so might as well declare a little bit
early and like get get some oxygen
though a third-party candidate doesn't
necessarily even need to start out in
iowa new hampshire because they're not
running in the primaries so they can go
wherever they like they can just make
their case they can do podcasts so there
will be a third party candidate who
declares in all likelihood before the
midterms but definitely before your end
they're taking a page out of the andrew
yang playbook
yeah if you will and
uh
do i i also have a little bit of uh you
know like whispering in the wind uh
coming my way on this yeah i'm sure i'm
sure people are
[Laughter]
hint
uh but that's good um
so one of the things we learned when we
were running for president was
um
i mean a whole bunch of things geez but
the big one was that the the mainstream
media that normally drives narratives
they're now way more reactive right um
they uh
they didn't realize bernie was a thing
until he was drawing massive crowd they
didn't realize you were a thing until
you were already you know doing well um
so there's a world you're saying that's
an an independent candidate can
go build up his or her notoriety on all
these alternatives and build up a
massive
following and then
who knows what that means come polling
time right yeah if you were a third
party candidate and you ran the numbers
you'd be like okay if i wait how does
that play out if i go early how does
that play out
uh and
it's not just
the
the media i mean you you'd get
a chance to build and hone your message
you'd get a chance to build
relationships with various people
on the ground
right now because of the discontent
with both parties uh you know if you
were a credible third party candidate
you could probably meet with like a
whole slew of people it would be like
well i should at least see if this
person's legit
um so someone who's in this vein i think
is gonna
make the plunge or take the plunge
um
sometime this year right probably
before the midterms again that'll be fun
to watch
yeah do you think we'll get them to are
they gonna run as an independent or we
can can you convince them to run as a
forward party
forwardist well i i'm saying
i'm saying that the person will be
running as a not as a non-democrat
non-republican got it who knows what
they run this cool yeah this is exciting
um will anyone else declare and i say
this because i want to i want to make
sure we remember this this is important
never forget andrew that john delaney
ran for president and aired a super bowl
ad in 2018.
you remember this i do remember yes um
and as someone who's run and managed
presidential campaign budgets that is an
a horrific way to blow a few million
dollars of your presidential budget
during the super bowl when your national
name id is approximately zero um
do you think any dems pull that pull of
john delaney not the super bowl thing
but declare really early that are
mainstream dams or are
on a major party line something like
that there was a story that came out in
politico this weekend about this very
thing um that will joe attract a primary
challenger yeah and this is one apparent
effect of buildback better not passing
is that the discontent
uh among democrats is higher than it
would have been if they'd gotten this
bill passed now i happen to think
buildback better is going to be
resuscitated there's going to be a
version of it it's going to keep
moving forward over this next period of
time
but uh this political story there are
two things i'd like to say one the
political story is trying to manufacture
this energy in a way because that loves
to try and love this yeah they'd love to
try and set people into ideological
camps and like the the article was
framed as like is the left like going to
the left challenge
joe
joe has had a relationship but he
reached out to this uh um but but they
what the article suggested i believe
correctly is that there is room for
someone to come and challenge joe
in the democratic primary now the person
is going to be very very far out of the
democratic establishment because you can
imagine anyone who's part of the
establishment does not want to
uh challenge joe you want me that guy
yeah you don't be that that that person
um but will someone if someone did
decide to run against
joe in a democratic primary
do they get 20 percent
if they're credible i believe they do
maybe better
and this is like the fascinating dynamic
of that this primary challenge
is that
any legit
primary challenge to a sitting president
is very very damaging to that sitting
president uh regardless of whether it's
successful or not right and so this is
one reason why
um
obama was deeply concerned about bernie
challenging in
2012 not because he thought bernie would
win
but because it's very it's very very
damaging uh and so
if someone runs
against joe in the democratic primary i
don't think they declare necessarily
this year they might declare at the end
of this year after the midterms like
december 22
[Music]
and if they do run against joe there are
a certain number of people that will
support them in that endeavor you know
among the democratic primary electorate
just because they joe might not have
been their person
uh if you look at
for example iowa joe did not do well
there right so there are a lot of people
who supported someone else
most of them will now be on board with
joe because he's the president he's the
leader of the party but will there be 20
of people uh who are excited about an
alternative probably yes of course and
so maybe more like 20 could be low um
and so
if you are a person who's on the outside
of the establishment and you see that
lane do you decide to take it
probably so probably someone does decide
to to challenge joe who's a
non-establishment figure
if you're a
main i don't know if that happens this
year though right if you're a mainstream
progressive if you're aoc or
elon or
you know i remember the squad or some of
the bigger names it probably doesn't
make sense because you're not going to
win
it'll make it look like your move
because you're facing the movement it'll
make you look like joe's squashing your
movement but if you're
maybe a lesser known progressive
um that wants to bump their name id out
there and fight for a lot of the same
policies it could make sense because
then you bump your name id you'll
probably see it someone's gonna do it oh
boy man we're in for we're in for a fun
couple years well this is again why i
say i appreciate this year because yeah
we don't have to deal with yeah like
after the midterms
all hell's going to break loose we'll
have so much time we have 11 months of
relative sanity
oh boy but i believe someone probably
declares and and that person
who declares you know there'll be some
attention to them they'll make some
progress during that time i i
if i was advising that person i i think
that it's not a bad move having been
through it myself i mean especially if
it's not gonna be a crowded field which
is not going to be because i think
i mean maybe but um if joe says he's not
running but it looks like he's going to
be running then it probably won't be
that crowded um then you get more
attention anymore when you actually get
speaking time in the debate stages you
know if you're one of the
three or four other candidates running
you know you know it's wild to just to
visualize this for a second that's why
i'm gonna play this out which i just
said because i disagree with it by the
way okay lay it on me which is that uh
you imagine that joe's gonna have to
debate whoever this person is
[Laughter]
oh you're saying it won't happen i don't
think i'd say it won't let him on
like
i highly doubt it's a thing and like if
you were if you were the democrats would
you want your 81 year old president
to like come and like stand there for
like you know an hour and debate like
progressive tv we're democrats right so
play it out okay so it's the democratic
primary there's a bunch of people
running
a couple people running you're jamie
harrison who's progressive right he's
none of the dnc you've got a woman of
color running against joe biden you're
gonna say she's silenced and doesn't get
to debate him that's a tough spot for
jamie right i don't know
they're gonna
yeah that that is that is an interesting
consideration
[Laughter]
but i don't so just you know like i
don't think that there are
um there definitely will be republican
debates yeah those would be fun those
are always fun they they drop the gloves
in the republican debates which are
hilarious the democrats are a little
more
subtly mean yeah and we can we can
return to what we think the republican
field will be
um but if you rewind to the
2016 race yeah when uh when trump beat
marco rubio ted cruz chris christie bush
yeah like you can imagine sort of like
like a smaller version of that because
that field was open and trump wasn't as
dominant than as he is now like there
are going to be a bunch of candidates
who do not run against trump because
they they see much more downside than
upside yeah
and then look trump stops you in those
debate stages i mean we studied them
when we were preparing for our debates
say we want about donald trump he's a
very very good debater i mean debating
is the wrong term but
it's about the attention economy he's
great at keeping the spotlight on him
and telling you to shut up yeah so if
you're a third-party candidate i guess
what i'm suggesting to you zack is they
don't actually show up on any debate
stage
until
the general election which won't be
until
fall 24
and right now the rules are that that
person would need to get higher than 15
percent right to make that stage but i
meant if you're a progressive you're
running
i think that person probably i i think
if if someone's a strong third-party
contender they probably surpassed 15.
they can get 15. yeah but if you're a
progressive
running the challenge joe biden on the
democratic ticket
would there be a debate and you're
saying they won't let them do it
that would be fun to watch
[Music]
let's go to next prediction my first one
was optimistic about web 3. my next one
is little isn't is darker um and maybe
we'll talk about this out loud but my
prediction is um
continued social decline
and really in other ways like there's
all these crazy stats and i think
they're going to really going down on a
limb against that
they're not that hot this is hotter
though
my prediction is some form of civil
unrest even before the election so you
got to get specific zach because you
know i mean there's a lot of stuff
that's gonna
go on you're right it's it's gonna be a
hot mess so here's my so new york times
wrote something today about um i sent it
to andrew because we had a speech from
when you ran for president called the
kids you said the kids are not all right
and it was basically about how adults
have put
themselves in front over their the adult
needs over the children's needs
the next generation is going to have it
worse than the previous generation i
think everyone knows that but the
numbers in this article were awful and
they're always awful and so it takes a
lot to shock me now but um
suicide attempts by 12 to 17 year old
girls which are already
skyrocketing we're up 51
in the pandemic
51
they were already through the [ __ ]
roof awful awful awful and
to me
you and i have been you've written a
book about it you've
run campaigns on we've been studying
this [ __ ]
for
since 2017 let's say right
and
some of it's come to roost and i think
it gets i think it's exponentially going
to get worse and so i don't know what
that means i think realistically it
plays out with like more real-life
cairns and fights on black friday and
fights in retail stores and people being
miserable in public
um
and probably comes to a head in 2024
election
but i think we're just going to be
collectively more miserable it's like a
fear of mine until we
kind of set some collective mission
together um as a country
um but i i just seeing these stats
whether it's automation or employment or
mental health these are things they're
getting worse it's gonna something comes
to a head at some point that comes ahead
in 2022 that's dark i think that they're
going to be massive mental health
challenges for young people in
particular
uh
i think your
plus away from schooling has been
really destructive uh for a lot of kids
i think my kids have fared okay
relatively speaking because they're
young
um but you know i talk to kids at
different ages and their parents and
it's like oh my gosh i forgot that you'd
like you know like missed junior year or
high school or whatever the heck it is i
mean they're like different things that
have happened to different people
um so you're not wrong i i do feel
really um
[Music]
bad for the next generation i felt bad
for the next generation back in 2017
2018 you would talk about
millennials yeah i mean we we've left
them a bill of goods in terms of an
ability to live a good life for
themselves and there are so many young
people that aren't having kids or aren't
getting married because they're looking
at it being like oh my prospects they
look up they see climate change like you
know and you like talk yourself into a
bunch of things
um whereas
you know like people weren't having
those kinds of conversations
right like a number of years ago i was
at a wedding this weekend
new year's eve wedding by the way really
fun
highly recommend um
but
there's a group of i i think everybody
was around my a little younger um
but they said some interesting and
the premise of what they were saying
wasn't 100 true but i'm curious your
thoughts on this because i want to frame
it to you
girl said
what is the hardest thing our parents
generation had to deal with on the macro
level
um and what she was saying was that the
millennial generation or gen z have now
had to deal with you know you start with
9 11 and the 2008
financial crash then the pandemic as
those are like massive and so climate
change in there these are massive
existential
foundation breaking
moments or crises um
and
my parents generation um
we're like what did they have anything
anywhere that near that scale i think
the answer is no but what we landed on
like somewhat facetiously laughing was
like yeah but um
a lot of them had some real trauma with
their parents and never ever talked
about their problems or like the way we
do you know so much like oh yeah yeah
never spoke to my father or whatsoever
right like that like i do think they
have it as you as i'm saying but my um
my question for you is i mean that same
question like is
you know it's prob you're probably
between where my parents are and what
what i am you got um 10 or so years on
me but gen x baby yeah baby you guys got
that like that little sweet spot a lot
of the things we joke about this whole
time a lot of things that were like
facts like you'll just work hard and get
to college and pay off buy a house like
those things are just bro
not only breaking down they're
essentially broken now are we
overreacting there um or is as bad as
i'm saying i mean
so i
by the numbers we have set up younger
people to fail at much higher levels
then certainly it was the case at any
earlier point uh and so that the numbers
that i had that i used were that if you
were born in the
1950s think there's like a 91
chance that you're going to do better
than your parents did if you were born
in the 90s then that's down to a 50 50
shot and i think we know where that's
trending i think it's just did you go
down
so and that's the definition of the
american dream you know like are you
going to do better than your parents and
a lot of kids are growing up being like
don't think i am going to do better than
parents a lot of parents are like don't
think you do better than me
so it's a shitty place yeah you know i
mean i'm the child of immigrants my dad
said something to me when i was a kid he
said it's not about how you're doing
it's about what direction you think
you're going um so it's like if you take
someone who's like you know really
struggling but
things are getting better then they're
like all right
like if you take someone who's really
affluent then you put them on a downward
slope they're going to be pissed off and
angry like that the entire time yeah so
that's what's happening now in america
for a lot of young people they look and
say like you know i don't think things
are trending up for me and by the way
they're generally not so
so that this is
what's fueling a lot of the
um the sadness the anger the despair and
and a lot of this stuff was true
pre-covered kova's just made it much
worse it's accelerated right yeah we did
a whole episode on and it's it's really
screwed up people's sense of well-being
you know it's like i i mean you'd have
to
be extraordinarily
um
resilient not to have felt that over the
last period of time right right so again
not sure about the value of this
prediction zach
you know
like hey people are too obvious
everything's going as [ __ ] or you would
you would need something very concrete
to
um measure whether this prediction pays
off
um so i'm just gonna put the pressure
back on you but i'm on to my third
prediction which is going to be much
more positive
uh i think this is the last year of the
pandemic i think 2022
uh
pandemic over
and here's my thinking okay number one
is that pandemics typically last uh
three years or so and you're not going
to believe these people but this is the
third [ __ ] year
it starts in 2020
then 2020 well this is 2022 this is year
three of the pandemic
so most pandemics will run their course
around this time of uh this time period
number two
omicron is everywhere yeah everywhere we
all have to accept that we're all gonna
get it i'm gonna break some more news
i'm pretty sure i had omicron i'm sure
we both have it
the studio is just crawling in omicron
uh and
it it now in my case you know i'd had
covid before as i was vaccinated like
everything else so um
you know it was really really mild but
this thing is everywhere and so if you
have a very very
infectious strain
then it ends up developing herd immunity
pretty quickly because you know it's
going to get to everyone i'm happy to
say
everything i've seen and what i've
experienced like this is pretty mild a
lot of people just have cold symptoms
and then we're like was that omicron it
was like
like it might have been in my case i was
mildly fatigued for like a couple of
days and i was like was that omicron
well now you can't really in certain
cities like in new york it's very
difficult to test right now very
difficult it's a problem so i think so
uh number two is that i think omicron is
going to spread everywhere and it's
going to give everyone some degree of
resistance
um and so that this is going to help
bring about the end of the pandemic
number three
is that we're all at the end of our rope
and so that there really is no
possibility of having folks
uh continue to adopt various counter
measures beyond something that's
relatively easy
uh because just get people are exhausted
yes um so i i think that the pandemic
ends in 22. it's kind of split on party
lines a little bit you're seeing it now
though where you have everything's open
but
schools because the teachers union
doesn't want to do it um
the knicks the jets the giants in new
york they're all packing their stadiums
but
certain places you can't gather more
than you know certain places still have
to feel like they're socially distant
like you're
you're seeing
somewhat like a little bit of hypocrisy
and like you we're distancing on some
ends but not but i i think to your point
we'll get the win we'll get to wit's end
i think it's a good prediction really go
down on a limb there
to me right now like the main thing you
have to be concerned about in my view is
the capacity of the healthcare system
it's like if the
you know when we talk about omicron
numbers like that the only number we
should be focusing on is hospitalization
yes like if a thousand people have mild
cold symptoms and no one ends up in the
hospital fine right
like if your hospital is beyond capacity
and it can't do elective procedures and
uh healthcare workers are burning out
right now that's that's a major problem
and if people in the hospital usually
means people are dying right yes
so that's your but if we're keeping
people out of hospital these are wins
these are wins we should be celebrating
um i agree that's the best pick
that 2022
is the end of the pandemic call to here
you
and anybody listens this
i think we've broadened beyond the end
gang which is exciting
[Music]
all right one pick that um we both agree
on um some we don't have to go crazy on
this but i had a point was that um
republicans are going to roll in the
midterms so do they get the senate to or
just the house i think they take both
zach thinks they take both i
concur
yeah
i have here is what i wrote down though
um
i was writing about this
in my book i took it out because i think
it's it might be too short term but i do
think that i wanted the book to like
stand a longer test of time but i do
think writing a book everyone comes
writing a book we're going to talk about
it more and more uh may 24th i think in
may um
but i think we start to see a rise of
crazy moderates
now hear me out and uh your thoughts on
this um i think eric adam's a fun
example um
but
in the sense that if the
if the whole system is incentivizing
people to go far right and far left
the average that's not the average vote
let's say the average general voter the
average human being is going to be
craving for people with just moderate or
nuanced views right and we're going to
be craving them so much that we will
overlook
aspects of crazy that we normally would
be turned off by but because they're not
like when it comes to being a leader
they're more moderate more flexible
um we'll tolerate it so for example eric
adams is a pretty weird dude like i mean
look at google eric adams rats like he
went on a tirade on he literally drowned
rats and poison at a city council
meeting like this guy does he he does
weird [ __ ] all the time but he's a
moderate he's tough on crime the
democrats are desperate for and they're
into that and it's you could go down the
list you could um i believe you're gonna
start to see like it's crazy and radical
to be a moderate in politics at least
for a little bit as we kind of sift out
this
far right far left uh hyper polarization
world i don't know you think maybe
eric's not maybe new york's anomaly i'm
not sure oh so one of the things that
that gets confusing too is that if you
look at um
at the numbers it's not like eric got a
mandate coming in you know what i mean
like i i don't i forget what he won his
base right yeah yeah and unclear what
lessons you can draw from from him
individually
um
are there more i think the word you're
looking for is zany
yeah like kind of zany moderates yeah
where like you just overlook the like
something that would have killed a
politician earlier but the fact is
they're like
well they're you know they're socially
liberal and fiscally conservative or
something moderate um so which party you
you thinking these people come out of
great question it's probably gonna be
more republicans
but i think you know i think you might
have a democracy what would be your
example of this person maybe
doctor
oz yes good example if he can come in i
don't know where's paul he's gonna be
yeah he's a republican
pennsylvania yep if he's gonna talk sane
is not a candidate say some things that
uh
isn't extremely pro-trump but isn't you
know so you're suggesting so this is a
different point than the point you were
making but we can go to some place a
little bit different this is i wanted to
talk it out so this is celebrities
because because memadaz is objectively a
celebrity there are people that
are getting courted to run for president
because they're celebrities i mean
donald trump is obviously a celebrity
you know
so will there be an openness to
celebrities
i'm going to
say yes to that
uh and
i think trump's running in 24 i think
he's the
heavy heavy favorite front runner uh in
the republican field and probably the
overall front-runner if you were to do
it today yeah um and so if that's your
context
uh are you looking for
um maybe another celebrity to to
i think like i don't know so celebrities
interesting because we've had
celebrities we've had jessie ventura we
had schwarzenegger we've had and then
you know caitlyn jenner got stomped
um
but she's one of the
most uh recognizable names on the planet
right um
but i do think it's about a platform
overall it's like why mayor pete was
able to run
um with no real name id but he had
he was a mayor so that was something he
was like it's almost like you see
something to
like being a celebrity isn't it but
something where you have uh a platform
or something like challenging
what's interesting is i think the dems
and republicans respond differently to
celebrities that's true is true and so
in the dem world
uh you know having mayor an extra name
is uh substantially better than uh yeah
actor yeah whereas republicans like yeah
don't care um it's one reason why there
are a lot of republicans who like me
and the democrats would be like oh you
know like
you know you haven't held up
republicans are like hey dude ran a
business and
done some things and no talk sets i'm
into it
um so uh it's one of the the overall
dynamics that the democrats are going to
be the last of the institutionalists
this is one reason why i individually or
forward it's like it's kind of its own
thing and the republicans are the
anti-institutionalists
uh and then and you're in a time when by
the way the institutions are not exactly
kicking ass they're not thriving yeah
yeah they're failing many of them
um and so
in a way what you need is kind of benign
outsiders
but
the democratic party will be hostile
towards even benign outsiders um which
is one reason why people are frustrated
i'm actually going to say something
funny i think bernie is a benign
outsider
benign to who
well it's just well intended do you want
one to do things to help people
um and the democratic party is trying to
you know kneecap right at every turn
like
um you know whereas the republicans it's
kind of generally like outsiders they're
like yeah you know come in and in my
view trump is you know
the wrong wrong wrong type of outsider
um
you know he's the opposite of the benign
one
um but that there there is like you know
who else i actually will also say was
like to me a benign outsider
tom steyer yeah we um and we used to
joke about this when we were running
government hadn't been has not been run
very well
in decades
yet
in order to
win a democratic primary or race you
have to have
experience running these poorly run
institutions well i made a joke about in
my book which was that like uh it's like
the test is like how can we be sure that
you also will get nothing done
[Laughter]
you know i mean yeah i forgot that yeah
the people take like kind of fake credit
for like oh under my watch like these
things happen i passed this bill that no
one's ever never heard of
we increased funding to xyz he was like
man that increases every year with or
without you you know
[Music]
i've seen a whole flurry of stories now
that are
waking up to the fact that democracy is
in jeopardy we're heading towards some
version of civil unrest certainly in 24
at the latest
you know uh that people are like wait a
minute like things aren't working so
well like that there are more people who
are waking up to that yeah now uh
there's a vox article about this um just
yesterday um
now the the tough part is that it's
getting cast in partisan terms again
because it's like hey the republicans
are trying to
you know keep people from voting like
you know veer towards authoritarianism
um and then the democrats are being
framed as like the saviors of democracy
and the rest of it and you're like i'm
not so sure about that like another way
out of this would be to actually just go
multi-party
like make it so that one party having
terrible
uh leadership doesn't imperil the entire
project right apparel the entire system
really the duopoly is is the problem now
i do think the issues in each party are
very different from each other
but there are
issues so that that's a dynamic that i'm
actually sort of encouraged by because
people are like wait a minute like we
really can't take any of this stuff for
granted going into 24. but i i am
optimistic on that with that um
the fire has been lit
under you know what the alarm has been
yeah
people are alarmed yeah people are
waking up to it i agree with that the
question is like what is the call to
action and a lot of folks are like the
call to action is like defeat
republicans and then you're like well
you know maybe you have to think a
little deeper than that
because like that you know like that's
the tribalism right yeah yeah and part
part of it might also be it's like you
know also being objective it's like
maybe like defeat republicans just plain
isn't going to work right it hasn't been
working
that way well it's you know both of us
think it's not going to work in 22 right
and then if you wind up with a
republican
held house or republican held both
houses of congress then obviously
nothing's going to get done out of
washington for the the next two years
and then you kind of stagger into
another election
my last um
you're making extra bonus predictions
you'll have one more wrap it down but i
want to do it i want your thoughts on it
okay i want your thoughts on censorship
in 2022 because i think we had talked
about the new twitter ceo is going to be
more
prone to ban proactive on banning people
marjorie taylor green just got kicked
off twitter after her fifth strike and
then so dan crenshaw who's a um
republican i think he's i think he's a
relatively moderate republican um
he said something interesting he doesn't
like marcia taylor green at all and he
said
this is a scam because here's what
happens twitter sets the rules to kick
you off their pla like what you need to
do to get kicked off
if you're marjorie taylor green you
break them every time and every time you
get booted you raise money saying that
you're being silenced and it's a scam
and
so my high level prediction is that i
think
big tech or the government is going to
be forced to these censorship
conversations that a lot of folks don't
want to have um because they're sticky
and they're not fun i'm more of a priest
uh i'm more of a free speech i'm more of
a free speech guy i think less
censorship is usually better but
i think everybody stuck between a rock
and a hard place on here because there
are elected officials saying horrific
things there is fox news approving
horrific things that have been for a
while right and even our mainstream you
know you can go msnbc cnn there's a
whole bunch of
issues with our media and entertainment
in this like
government overlap
thoughts on does this come to a head in
2022 um any predictions on how this
plays out this year as as politics
starts heating up too this is going to
be an issue in 22 i think it's going to
be a much bigger deal in 23 yeah uh
after trump redeclares and then uh is
everyone going to then be like well
can't ban a dude who's
running for office again and people have
elected yeah and then maybe he becomes
the nominee again and that won't happen
until 24 and then it's like well you
certainly can't take it away from the
nominee so um so i i think it's going to
be an issue in 22 i think it's going to
be a bigger issue
immediately afterwards i guess like the
prediction is like buckle up for
censorship conversations it's um
gonna i think the free speech
our principles of free speech are gonna
be tested and so and i i do have a
different perspective on this too yeah
it's like people like complain about
what twitter does twitter's a private
company the government is its own
category
but people act like the like twitter is
you know somehow
public comments um it's not and to be
fair like donald trump says i don't like
what twitter does i'm gonna make my own
right wing twitter and
i think that's a lot too fine
as long as you know you're not
promoting violence or whatever our basic
rules are um the hardest part to me is i
think um the average person not paying
attention not knowing what's getting cut
out or what's getting kept in i think is
always the hardest part where we said um
when we had run for office where
you were left off or ignored in certain
ways like the average person watching
who's relying on these entertainment
companies for news i think it's that's
that's the hardest part right and i
think people are waking up to that and i
think there's more we can do
in the alternative media space and
podcasts like this but
that's the challenge um
but i'm i'm buckled up for a censorship
i don't want to say war censorship
debate
in 2022. i i would agree with you that
there is much much more questioning of
the mainstream media even than ever
you know they have like a splintering
then you have growth of various
alternative voices
uh you know joe rogan's the most
prominent right and you you see that joe
rogan
is
very much just like actively
going against uh certain
um mainstream
media narratives uh and
like the antagonism is really
interesting in the sense that like i i
think that
now it's explicit in a way that before
they were almost on like parallel tracks
in like different worlds and then now
you can see like the streams crossing
and
clashing
to to a higher degree i'm reading the
loudest voices in the room the story of
um
basically how roger ailes built fox news
um i'm only into chapter one right now
chapter two from there but um
these are
versions of their massive power
structures is what i think that's the
hardest part right they have
swayed elections in popular opinion and
they're highly profitable it's like this
capitalism and government power wielding
all come into one right and that's
what's
um
in some ways disintegrating in some ways
evolving somebody's changing um
so anyway more to come on that for sure
that's our
prediction episode man 2022
what did i say
inflation sticks around there's a third
party candidate who declares this year
and it's the end of the pandemic that's
pretty good and i say web 3 main streams
a bit
we have a bit of a mental health social
decline
and sadly the republicans going to win
the midterms
that's an easy one and then maybe
censorship we're not sure what happens
in censorship but i think we have a
debate
anyway
good episode it's gonna be a good year
this is our year andrew this is the year
enjoy 2022
really do some great stuff give yourself
something to look forward to i am pumped
for this year too see you next week
folks
[Music]
you